je suis le père d'un cyborg lucas il a
bientôt huit ans chasseur de pokémon
joueurs de jeux vidéo est fan de super
héros je dois vous dire que son
évolution me questionne fortement je
suis venu ici pour vous exposer une
problématique que j'ai dans la tête
depuis un certain temps cela va me faire
du bien de vous en parler aujourd'hui
car je suis taraudé par une question est
ce que lucas n'est-il pas en train de
devenir un trans humains trans humains
trans humaniste transhumanisme il faut
que je il faut que je vous dise de quoi
il retourne c'est quoi le transhumanisme
un mouvement philosophique culturels
scientifiques technologiques qui prend l
usage des technosciences afin
d'améliorer les capacités physiques et
cognitives de l'individu objectif
affiché éliminer la maladie le handicap
la souffrance le vieillissement et au
delà
vaincre la mort vaincre la mort il ya
plusieurs formes de transhumanisme et
plusieurs courants plus ou moins
radicaux et qui parfois s'opposent mais
concrètement qu'est ce que c'est le
transhumanisme l'homme pourra peut
pourra être augmentée dans ses capacités
physiques et cognitives réparé jusqu'à
dépasser sa condition d'homo sapiens
pour devenir un homme 30 humain or voilà
c'est clair je suis le perdent ainsi un
cyborg lucas a l'air de trouver ça
parfaitement dans malin d'avoir des
super-pouvoirs d'intégrer des
technologies dans son corps vous voyez
sa culture manga pokémon films jeux
vidéo
tout cela me confirme une chose il
pourra devenir un jour spider man ou
iron man ou les deux et dans cette salle
vous n'y couperez pas un les parents de
jeunes enfants
sachez que vos enfants deviendront
eux-mêmes très bientôt des cyborgs alors
augmenter réparé
qu'est ce qu'on entend par là finalement
est-ce que c'est pas une tendance
naturelle de l'homme de s'appuyer sur
l'artificiel à travers les sciences et
les technologies pour dépasser sa
condition d'animal ça des courses à
conditions originel est ce que l'homme
s'extrait de sa nature originelle pour
finalement s'affirmer comme un être
humain en s'appuyant souvent sur son
imaginaire technologique
en fait il existe une petite histoire
nacht naturel de l'artifice l'homme ces
artifices ya lise et c'est dans sa
nature profonde depuis le silex
préhistorique
l'homme n'a cessé d'inventer des
techniques pour augmenter ses capacités
d'appréhension et de maîtrise de réel
qui l'entourent l'informatique le modèle
computationnelle ou où le numérique le
paradigme numérique c'est comme vous
voudrez l'informatique est aujourd'hui
le moteur central de cette volonté de
l'homme de dépasser ses limites
pour commencer je vous annonce la
disparition de l'ordinateur alors
peut-être pas la disparition en fait la
dilution de l'ordinateur vous n'aurez
plus bientôt conscience même de
l'existence des ordinateurs pourquoi
parce qu'ils seront diluées diffusé dans
tous les éléments du réel qui nous
entoure
l'informatique est en train de devenir
invisible et ubiquitaire concrètement ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que tout objet du réel
artificielle ou biologiques d'ailleurs
aura bientôt les fonctions d'un
ordinateur connecté au réseau
c'est à dire la capacité de calcul
algorithmique associé au pouvoir
d'envoyer et de recevoir de recevoir des
données exploitables
le premier acte très vite très concret
on préfigure que aux alentours de 2020
c'est à dire dans deux ans 20 à 30
milliards d'objets connectés existeront
sur la planète un arbre un immeuble une
bactérie une vache des molécules votre
plante verte seront désormais des
machines algorithmique communicante la
société botanicals vous vendez petit
capteur d'humidité pour vos plantes
vertes ces petits capteurs sont
connectés un compte twitter qui envoie
un tweet est votre plan de vous par là
votre peau vous envoie un tweet à me
first i j'ai soif
i'm very first y jetteraient soif et
puis si vous ne la rose et plus i'm dead
au milieu des années 40 un ordinateur
comme leygnac faisait plusieurs
centaines de mètres carrés et l'être
humain déambulait dans l'ordinateur à
l'intérieur de l'ordinateur
on a vu au cours du temps des années 50
60 en 10 80 on a vu la diminution
croissante de la taille de l'ordinateur
et de son coût de transportable il est
devenu portable puis la tablette
la liseuse le smartphone que devient
l'informatique bien un outil nomade et
ubiquitaire votre téléphone est un
ordinateur
pourquoi parce qu'il est équipé d'un
système d'exploitation c'est donc un
ordinateur
la vraie analyse au delà du nomadisme de
l'informatique est ce que l'on remarque
en termes anthropologique
c'est que l'ordinateur se rapproche du
corps il se rapproche du corps et il va
bientôt les l'intégrer l'homme sera
hybride et est intégré comme un
ordinateur il fonctionnera de la même
manière et cette hybridation de l'homme
et de la machine cette fusion homme
machine c'est ce que revendique
justement le mouvement transhumaniste
ceci n'est pas nouveau et l'artificiel
la technique est depuis bien longtemps
le moyen d'augmenter les capacités
biologiques de l'homme une paire de
lunettes est une prothèse un pacemaker
un sonotone une
un stérilet le plombage ça fait très
longtemps
en fait on intègre les technologies plus
intéressant encore le tatouage et le
piercing qui sont aujourd'hui des
pratiques totalement généralisé et
presque banalisés il est presque
marginal de ne pas avoir un tatouage
aujourd'hui on sent bien que
sociologiquement les gens ont intégré
lancre lancre à l'intérieur et puis le
métal sur le corps en fait l'homme n'a
jamais cessé de convoquer l'artifice
comme moyen d'évoluer d'évoluer par
rapport à sa condition naturelle
d'origine alors qu'est ce qui est
nouveau
qu'est ce qui est nouveau aujourd'hui
puisque je suis en train de vous dire
que cette histoire finalement et naturel
d'intégrer les technologies ce qui est
nouveau c'est le développement
ahurissant aujourd'hui des sciences et
de la combinaison de ces centaines entre
elles qui sont en train de nous faire
entrer dans un nouveau monde un nouvel
ordre civil siviglia civilisationnel une
autre vision du monde qui se met en
place
le problème c'est que 99% des humains ne
sont ni conscient donc ne sont pas
conscients de cette évolution n'ont même
pas conscience
ces technologies sont tellement complexe
que la conscience au quotidien de ce qui
est en train de se passer
s'évanouit d'où le fait que j'aimerais
partager ce questionnement avec vous
nanotechnologies bio technologie
biologie de synthèse sciences cognitives
ingénierie génétique tout ça combiné
avec la puissance des calculs
algorithmes algorithmique emmène
progressivement l'humain vers un nouveau
destin
le trans humain une nouvelle espèce
d'homme alors mon fils lucas sera
augmentée réparé
passons en revue quelques technologies
ou la réalité va bientôt dépasser la
science fiction le corps d'abord encore
le corps de lucas sera contrôlé et géré
par une série de capteurs internes ou
externes afin d'analyser le
fonctionnement de certains organes
en temps réel et recueillir toutes
sortes de données produites par le corps
des puces connecté intégrant un
processeur feront du corps un ordinateur
qui produit des données en temps réel
transmissibles aux services médicaux aux
médecins google société dont le
directeur scientifique est l'un des plus
grands théoriciens du transhumanisme
rikers veille
et bien google va proposer à travers des
puces et des capteurs d'établir un
système de diagnostic de santé en temps
réel de l'être humain et de pouvoir
ainsi prédire les problèmes de santé à
venir des nano particules injectées dans
le sont peuvent tracer les dérèglements
de certains organes
ils transmettent cette information
médecins en live le cas
lucas saura sûrement s'il va devenir
malade avant même d'en ressentir les
effets concrets concernant maintenant
les yeux de lucas il devient sur ne
viendront sûrement les interfaces du
futur les yeux deviennent des écrans
connectés au réseau en temps réel grâce
à des futurs lentilles de connexion en
réalité augmentée on a vu déjà les
google classe sortir ce sont déjà les
prémices de ces écrans ces écrans yeux
on a d'abord un élément technologique
mais bientôt les lentilles connectés
feront disparaître la présence physique
de ces éléments technologiques
le tableau de bord de la future voiture
automatique de lucas seront ses yeux
mieux encore la société pixum vision
propose déjà des dispositifs rhétiques
réticulaire oculaire permettant de
pallier à ce plusieurs forme de cécité 1
il ya des problèmes oculaires système
bionique de restauration de la vision la
peau maintenant de l'udc à la peau de
luca la peau devient un an
ce tactile grâce à des tatouages
connecté permettant d'augmenter le
volume de la musique d'ouvrir une porte
de communiquer avec un objet ou de
transmettre et recevoir des systèmes
d'info des informations là par simple
effleurement de la peau oubliez vos
smartphones oublier les tablettes
oublier toutes ces technologies qui
aujourd'hui sont encore nomades et
s'intégreront et le corps de lucas et tu
deviendras une interface global est
connecté le cas pourra aussi être réparé
la possibilité prochaine de produire des
organes biologique dans des fermes
d'organes à travers la technologie du
bioprint et l'imprimante 3d reproduire
la peau reproduire des organes les
modifier les changer alors comme je ne
veux pas être je ne veux pas perdre pied
par rapport à cette évolution et par
rapport à mon fils lucas mon enfant
cyborg et j'ai l'intention de comprendre
comment il va réagir comment il va
percevoir tous ces changements alors à
la rentrée je vous annonce que je vais
aller aller à une hymne plan de partie
oui je vais me faire implanter des puces
nfc
vous voyez des puces nfc dans les
créneaux les mains qui pourront
commander des objets des actions 1
produire de l'information et en diffuser
j'oubliais le cerveau le cerveau de le
cas le cerveau de mon fils certains
scientifiques et entrepreneurs dans les
biotechnologies imagine pouvoir très
bientôt remplacer les synapses de votre
cerveau par des nanotubes de carbone
c'est à dire par un élément artificiel
si vous avez un synapses défectueux on
pourra le le remplacer par ce petit
nanotubes de carbone qui s'y bridera qui
réparera lucas problème à l'échelle
moléculaire nanotechnologies les
molécules du neurone biologique
s'hybrident rompt avec ceux du nanotube
de carbone
conclusion ne pourront bientôt plus
distinguer ce qui est d'ordre biologique
ou d'ordre artificiel j'oublie aussi
l'avènement des interfaces neuronale
dispositif de communication directe
entre le cerveau une machine externe un
ordinateur un appareil électronique un
objet connecté la possibilité pour un
handicapé moteur par le simple pouvoir
de la pensée de déplacer son fauteuil ou
de déplacer des objets ces
expérimentations sont déjà en cours et
sont réalisés dans plusieurs
laboratoires dans le monde la société
neurol inc société appartenant à elon
musk très grands milliardaires
américains et très grands industriels et
scientifiques
la société neuro link propose d'experian
expérimente en semant des implants
cérébraux permettant d'augmenter les
capacités intellectuelles de l'homme en
se connectant à des bases de données
il ya des systèmes d'information en
ligne la mémoire de lucas sera infinie
si le cas à des problèmes génétiques des
gènes défectueux
la technologie christopher kas 9 est une
technique qui existe depuis 2012 permet
de copier supprimer modifier ou ajouter
des gènes à la demande et de concevoir
des organismes mutants pratiquement à la
chaîne la série des films x man
si chère à lucas qui propose des
aventures de mutants au pouvoir varier
l expression de ce bricolage génétique
au cours du développement de son
développement on voit se dessiner
l'avenir des êtres humains des êtres
humains augmenté réparé et face à ceux
qui n'auront pas les moyens de se payer
ces technologies fracture sociale
fracture numérique mais qui permettront
de générer un être humain plus
intelligent ayant des capacités plus
importantes et de reculer les limites de
la vie jusqu à l'immortalité
peut-être je serai le dernier humain
mortel mortels
de ma famille et lucas le premier trans
humain d'une ligne est sans fin si
l'humain qui s'hybrident avec la machine
pause sans aucun doute des questions
éthiques philosophiques et politiques
c'est oublier un autre danger beaucoup
plus dense et où l'homme pourrait perdre
la maîtrise de son destin
si l'homme intègre les technologies la
machine elle est en train de superviser
se naturaliser d'imiter l'homme de
devenir autonome et collaborative cette
machine qui s'autonomise ça s'appelle
l'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle sera
sûrement la vraie problématique de mon
fils lucas et peut-être un jour un
ennemi redoutable l'intelligence
artificielle pourrait très prochainement
dépasser l'intelligence biologique et de
l'homme elle va bientôt permettre aux
machines de se comporter comme des
humains et sans intervention extérieure
l'homme a toujours voulu créer des
répliques de lui même des automates des
répliques artificielle ou biologique
le joueur d'échecs du xviiie siècle
l'automate qui joue aux échecs au xviiie
siècle le robot humanoïde ou même encore
le mythe de frankenstein l'homme a
toujours voulu c'est un fantasme a
toujours et depuis longtemps voulu créer
des artefacts mécanique ou biologiques
de lui même
l'intelligence artificielle en est
l'aboutissement l'ordinateur d'ibm ibm
très puissant bas depuis plusieurs
années déjà les plus grands joueurs
d'échecs
très récemment le programme alpha go de
google toujours a battu plusieurs fois
le champion du monde 2 go beaucoup plus
inquiétant
l'avènement des agents conversationnels
dit chaque potes c'est petit chat bottes
sont des petits avatars qui se
connectent à des bases de données et
vous parle en langage naturel comme un
humain exactement comme un humain en
programmant ses avatars
on va pouvoir réserver un restaurant
écouter une histoire négocier une vente
avant
l'avatar va négocier une vente
immobilière à votre place 1 où vous
raconter des blagues ce qui est d'abord
conçu comme un service pourrait bientôt
échapper au contrôle de l'homme ces
machines peuvent apprendre d'elles mêmes
s'auto-organiser et collaborer entre
elles
très récemment fin du mois de juin les
laboratoire d'intelligence artificielle
de la société facebook ont vu une chose
tout à fait exceptionnel deux de ces
stades bottes ont inventée ensemble un
langage non compréhensibles par les
humains et ont commencé à collaborer
entre elles ces signes précurseurs de
cette autonomie de la machine qui se
comporte comme un humain eh bien on y
pose d'énormes même problématique
l'intelligence artificielle peut
maintenant se développer et se
reproduire sans l'aide de l'humain
l'écrivain philip k.dick très grand
écrivain américain
une sorte de jules verne français dont
vous connaissez de nombreux titres en
fait à travers le les adaptations
cinématographiques blade runner total
recall minority report
cet écrivain philip k.dick dans un petit
roman absolument géniale qui s'appelle
ubik des cris des cris son héros qui est
dans un appartement et dans cet
appartement
tout est payant la douche est payante le
placard est payant le petit déjeuner est
payant l'accès à l'information et des
plaignants est payant tout est payant et
évidemment s'il ne paye pas et bien le
héros
ils n'acceptent pas à son service je
vous poursuivrait en justice dit la
porte aux héros récalcitrants du bic qui
n'a pas les moyens de payer
alors finalement la ville
tables véritable combat n'est-il pas
celui de l'homme trans humains votre
descendance votre descendance
face à cette intelligence artificielle
qui n'a plus d'humanité ou plutôt qui
limite
nous sommes dans cette salle sûrement
les derniers spécimens de l'homo sapiens
et nous devons nous attendre à rentrer
en dialogue avec l'homo artificialisés
artificialisés trans humaniste c'est à
dire vos enfants et vos petits enfants
ce sont de futurs citoyens ce sont de
futurs citoyens
ils vont pouvoir voter choisir des
règles une éthique il est temps que vous
les accompagnez vous les sensibiliser
vous vous soyez au courant de tous ces
enjeux afin finalement de répondre à une
question très importante
le transhumanisme le transhumanisme
n'est pas une question technologique aux
scientifiques mais bien elle est bien
une question politique et c'est à vous
d'accompagner vos enfants sur cette
vision politique que recouvre ce terme
de transhumanisme
[Musique]